cosmetics have been breaking gamers bank
accounts for years and years now but
sometimes
you've got to look good to play good
some skin connoisseurs just want to
collect them
all while others want to represent their
favorite players and teams
some of them change the look of your
weapons and some change the look of your
entire character
but one thing that everyone can agree on
is that certain skins
are just sexy some skins look so good
that you just
can't resist buying them some skins are
so rare that if you don't buy them
you'll never see them again so here are
the top 10
sexiest skins
kicking off our list is one of
counter-strike's rarest skins
the orb dragon lore oh my god no way i
got a dragon lore
i got a dragon lore please no
get away no way in july 2014
the cobblestone collection was added to
cs go and featured the first weapon
with the covert rarity tag but this case
also featured consumer and industrial
tier skins which meant that the chances
of
actually opening a case and getting a
dragon law is roughly
one in 2.5 million so you can understand
why some people get pretty excited when
they unbox one
i told you dude
the dragon law is a thing of beauty but
you don't have to take our word for it
plenty of pros use dragon laws of their
own and
famously kenny s made his name as csgo's
most
legendary author using a dragon lore
named the magic stick
can he he's inside of this he's trying
to play clever with this awp and he's
got one no
no way kenny you gotta stop the price of
a factory new orc dragon law can vary
given that these things don't sell every
day but they can go for
thousands of dollars but hey you could
always buy a cobblestone case for a
couple of hundred bucks
and test your luck instead of your
wallet
taking our number nine spot are the only
skins to become a pop
sensation kda
the kda skins in league of legends were
released in november 2018
following the release of the group's
music video for their hit song
pop stars and apparently they sold well
because riot will
not stop releasing more and more kda
content
[Music]
the kda skins are some of the most
elaborate and beloved skins in league at
this point
even if sometimes riot screws up the
marketing a little holly got a job
kylie go to work always on fire don't
get burnt i try not to get burned
but it's not always easy when you're
spitting hot flames
at number eight on our list is a
balanced skin that might actually make
you
better at the game why do i get
headshots why do i aim better
why do i just feel better playing with
the prime vandal the prime skin set has
been invalorant since
june and as soon as it came out people
started thinking
it might somehow be pay to win is the
prime vandal better than any other gun
i don't really know this is kind of the
meme that's been running around is that
the prime vandal is just the best vandal
now the prime vandal probably doesn't
actually make you better a head shot
but there's no denying that it looks
sick maybe that little visual
confidence boost is what's convincing
people it's secretly op
maybe i was actually thinking about it i
might actually go to the prime because i
actually really like the look of the
yellow prime
and just the animations and the prime
basically feels like a aimbot
and the number seven spot is the only
skin on this list that's
actually literally sexy street fighter
5's hot ryu street fighter 5
launched with ryu's shirtless bearded
battle costume but fans quickly
nicknamed it something a little more
appropriate
hot ryu and that name burst a meme
here is a close-up of the box art we got
ryu and chinley here on the front and
they're
hot edition a little bit more skin than
usual fans all over the world were
falling in love with this shirtless
bearded man and
soon enough capcom got in on the action
they officially changed
the skin's name to hot ryu and started
making
action figures in his honor here you can
see two pixel pals that are still in the
box luigi
and hot ryu which it's hilarious to me
that he's called hot ryu it's because he
has no shirt and a beard
which apparently makes you very
attractive
driving into the number six spot now we
have rocket league's gold rush
we did it ladies and gentlemen we have
the alpha boost
i'm so hyped man i'm so freaked out
often referred to as alpha boost this
item was given to players who
participated in the game's
alpha test it's rocket league's most
expensive item
by a long shot coming in at roughly 5
000 us dollars at the moment
and the price has only continued to rise
since the game's launch in 2015.
i am finally a proud owner
of the
alpha boost baby we got it
flying in at number five we have
overwatch's pink mercy
because nothing is sexier than donating
to charity
helping those in need is its own reward
when pink mercy was introduced in may
2018
alongside a charity campaign all
proceeds from the skin
went to the breast cancer research
foundation that means that if you own
this skin you are the ultimate support
player
pink musty means you're a messy mane and
if you don't have the skin i'm afraid
you simply
aren't a real mercy mane overwatch
players helped raise over 12.7
million us dollars for the charity in
just two weeks
and once the skin was no longer on sale
fans
begged blizzard to bring it back but for
now we can only hope that maybe one day
pink mercy will reappear in the shop
sliding into number four is the
flashpoint race skin from apex legends
it quickly became one of the most sought
after skins in the apex community when
it hit the shop
in june 2019 and it's not hard to see
why it's one of the most radical costume
changes for wraith
shaving her head and putting her in an
uncharacteristic bright blue outfit
but stop us if you've heard this one
before respawn
stop selling the skin so just like pink
mercy
fans begged the apex devs to put it back
up for sale
literally the only thing i want in this
game is flashpoint i will give away all
my skits for flashbacks
what do i have to do josh to make you
guys re-put this in the game
unlike basically any other limited
edition skin though
respawn actually listened in march they
brought back the skin in a season 8
update so now anyone can get their hands
on this
beauty coming in at the number 3 spot
is the legendary black eye skin line
from rainbow six siege
all purple purple purple oh i got black
eyes for buck
c8
the black eye skins in rainbow six siege
are the rarest
in the game with less than a two percent
chance of them dropping
when you open an alpha pack in the game
oh
epic black guys oh [ __ ]
let's go now black eye skins haven't
been released yet for
shields but about a year ago some
players found
in-game files for them and with ubisoft
teasing them in some of their preview
videos
hopefully we will see some black ice
shields pretty soon
taking our runner-up spot now we have
valance ruin dagger
introduced as part of the episode 1 act
3
battle pass this melee weapon was
awarded to players who completed
all 50 tiers of the pass and then
finally the knife
the dagger the ruin dagger this is me
100 my new knife
i'm only going to use this knife for now
on i need a i need to only play games on
this account so i can get this knife
unlocked
this was riot's first rendition of
counter-strike's beloved karambit but
compared to the other knight in the game
the ruin dagger featured new uniquely
satisfying animations
last but not least the nice looking ruin
dagger
that looks like those cs go skins that
you see certainly i have flex on the
noobs while using the ruben dagger right
the karambit unfortunately if you
weren't able to complete the battle pass
from that act
you didn't get the skin and chances are
you likely won't be getting another
chance to earn this knife
ever again we couldn't just leave you
with only one knife on this list so we
decided that the number one spot
had to go to cs go's butterfly knife
this video is about the butterfly knife
or as i like to call it the best knife
in the game
these were some of the first knives ever
introduced to the game
and they've been asked here ever since
oh
god i like it yes stewie's got that
and the follow-up released back in 2012
valve has just never managed to create
something that can
top it doesn't matter if you're using a
doppler or a fade there is simply
no cs go skin sexier than a butterfly
knife
and they've been part of some iconic cs
go moments
he has a glock of course and he's able
to hit and j somehow out of bullets on
the knife skadoodle what's he doing a
double knife
can he get the third he gets the right
click and rush finds gaps
smoked out bomb down everyone chasing
down gets a tremor the knife comes in
simple of course stabs him straight in
the chest
in a game like counter strike there
isn't much else you look at more than a
knife and if you don't think that this
thing is sexy then
i don't know what is just look at these
animations
alright guys what did you think of that
did i miss out any good ones that
should have made it onto the list don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you haven't done so already
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
oh you got it
what is he doing
oh i think i just broke my nose because
i face planted my